[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOU DE LA TORRE:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Google Cloud
Video Learning Series.
My name is Lou De La Torre.
I'm a customer engineer
at Google Cloud.
And today I'll show
you how to export
logs from Google Cloud
Logging to BigQuery.
Here I am in the
Google Cloud console.
You can quickly find
the BigQuery service
by typing BigQuery in the Search
Products and Resources field
and then selecting BigQuery.
In the Navigation pane
in the Resources section,
select your project.
On the right side of the
window in the Details panel,
click Create Dataset.
In the Create dataset
window under Dataset ID,
enter a unique name.
In Data location, accept
the default, which is US.
In Default Table Expiration,
select Number of Days
After Table Creation,
and I'll enter 7.
Under Encryption, accept the
default Google-managed key
and select Create Dataset.
Next, we'll want to turn on
audit logging for all services.
By default, data
access audit logs
are disabled except
for BigQuery.
In order to enable
all audit logs,
we'll need to first download the
current IAM policy as a file,
then add the audit
log policy yaml object
to the current policy file,
then update our project
with the updated policy.
I'll demonstrate how to
configure your project's data
access audit logs using the
gcloud command and Google Cloud
console.
First, open the cloud shell
by clicking on Activate Cloud
Shell.
Then read the project's IAM
policy and store it in a file
by running this command.
Click on Authorize
Cloud Shell if prompted.
Then edit the policy file stored
in temp/policy.yaml using VI,
and add the data access
audit logs configuration.
Be sure to preserve
the bindings and ETag
sections without changes.
Otherwise, you might cause your
project to become unstable.
Save and exit the file, then
write the new IAM policy
to the project by
running this command.
Next, we'll need to refine the
logging filters to export audit
logs, including admin activity
and data access audit logs.
You could also enable logs
for specific resource types
if you like.
We'll use the gcloud
logging sinks create command
to create a sink called
gcp_logging_sink_bq
for the project by
running this command.
In the service account entry,
return from the API call.
The identity is included
in the response.
This identity represents a
Google Cloud Service account
that has been created
for the export.
Until you grant this
identity write access
to the destination, log-entry
exports from the sink
will fail.
So let's go ahead and
copy the identity.
To add the permissions
to the service account,
select the data set.
In my case, gcp_logging_export,
and select Share dataset.
In the Add members
field, paste the service
account that we just copied.
Then select a role.
Select BigQuery
and BigQuery Data
Editor to provide the
permissions necessary.
Click Add, and click Done.
After you create the logging
export by using this filter,
log files begin to populate
the BigQuery dataset
in the configured project.
You can now run a broad range
of queries against the audit
logs to better understand who's
accessing data on Google Cloud,
or you can use a tool
like Google Data Studio
to help you visualize the data.
Well, that concludes the demo.
Please stay tuned
for future videos
on how to use other components
of the Google Cloud Operation
Suite as well as other services.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]